the bi-annual ritual of changing our
clocks could become a thing of the past
if senators get their way the senate
unanimously has to bill that would make
daylight savings time permanent it's not
law yet but as scott mcfarland reports
suddenly there's growing momentum scott
good morning this is good news for a lot
of people
vlad good morning to you without warning
and without objection the senate passed
the sunshine protection act which makes
daylight saving permanent keeps it in
place for good now it's on to the u.s
house with the chairman of the powerful
house energy committee tell cbs news
quote i'm pleased to see momentum
building on the impacts of springing
forward and falling back it's clear to
me that it's time to stop changing our
clocks twice a year
despite the bipartisanship though
there's no vote on the calendar and no
commitment from house leadership to do
so but here in congress last week
medical experts testified before the u.s
house that during the twice a year clock
changing the rates of heart attack
stroke and sleep disorder all rise if
this becomes law it takes effect in
november 2023 which gives time to adjust
to the stopping of the adjusting of
clocks don't he
yeah time time for the buses and the
trains and the planes to adjust i can
adjust you know right now if they
changed it scott thank you very much i'm
a big fan of this yeah everybody is well
i used to be opposed guys because i like
that extra hour of sleep but clearly the
advantage is far outweigh the negatives
so i've changed especially the ones of
people getting sick
heart attacks that's not good fix it
congress i'm on board all right parents
don't want nap schedules thrown off
anymore it's so confusing i don't know
when they're supposed to go down all
right scott thank you very much rooting
for that bill